對全盞跟婚姻的共同遺憾
就是我太晚遇到小哥了
小哥的遺憾是什麼
我告等
沒教堂啦
我們這個廣納各家滷蛇
每個禮拜就聚會一次
後來賺到去沖繩教堂辦婚禮
參加的時候他只有十萬塊
對
他後來已經到三百多萬了
小哥沒潑的他不要
沒潑洞的不要
十二塊到十二塊
我混了半年
那你看一下他的全盞
我就一路下跌
補習去買那個
你不敢碰的股票
越腰越好
好
腰股才可以
最會法說的股票
還有這種
法說王啊
大波動
大波動都在法說會的隔天
每一次這種重大時間的法說
他都漲停反
保了 保了
小哥
你知道為什麼
今天我們要站著開場嗎
為什麼
因為今天我們要迎來
李才達林秀史上最刺激的一集
太刺激了
要幹嘛嗎
對 要幹嘛嗎
我們是理財節目嗎
我們是理財節目
你知道最多的留言
跟我們是留什麼嗎
也不知道耶
支持小哥壽石公斤
支持
所以我們歌有仇必報
歌有重必良
我們承諾觀眾的
我們就要做到
拍手
好
今天現場
我們準備了一個體重劑
造華要良
小哥也要量
然後我們這一季錄完的話
小哥要受10公斤
趙華要受5公斤
好不好 各位網友
你可以留言猜猜看
我們這一季錄完的時候
小哥會受幾公斤
趙華會受幾公斤
會不會先10台斤
我覺得10台斤比較簡單
不行 公斤公斤
猜中的話
各位網友我們可以送小哥
夾到的一個大娃娃一個
所以大家趕快踴躍留言
這一季
哥有籌幣報錄完
小哥會受幾公斤
趙華會受幾公斤
也可以說胖喔
也沒有問題喔
最準的網友
我們送你一個小哥夾到的大娃娃
好不好
好啦 誰先
小數點下一位喔
小數點下一位是不是
這麼嚴苛啊
不然大概1234有些削90
隨便採都拆掉
小數點下一位 小數點下一位
誰先兩
你先 你先
我先 Lady first
因為我要看我是你的幾倍
我跟你講
趙華第一次要在大家前面公布體重嗎
好喔
深呼吸
CARD 史上最高欸
史上最高喔
你為了那個喔 你為了要
我跟你講 我是為了拉高以後放空出貨好不好
喔知道了 主力拉高出貨
好 我量完了
我是上禮拜都大吃大喝
烤肉啊 炸物啊
對 拉高之後放空
我最近也沒有什麼節制欸
我看一下是多少
我看一下 我看一下
唉唷
小哥從錄影剛剛到現在已經瘦了1公斤
怎麼猜100多而已
我還以為100多欸
小哥
對啦 因為假如100多的話
我就說我一定會少一位數
現在不能拿獎了
好 你不能公布你的數字
好 好 好
不要讓網友猜我們會瘦多少
OK 好不好
所以我們今天的
歌有仇必報的開場
就是這麼刺激啦
太刺激了 真的
接下來還有更刺激的
好 網友挑戰你
網友挑戰你
我們來看看網友提出了
非常多的問題來
傳人局我們小哥
全陣小哥居然被網友傳人局說
全陣都是騙人的啦
怎麼說咧
我們來看看網友的問題是什麼
好 沒問題
來看看
還是覺得好難喔
會被玩到脫褲的感覺
啪啪
我覺得被玩到脫褲的感覺
滿好的
這什麼遊戲
為什麼可以這麼好玩到脫褲
對啊
為什麼跟小哥玩會玩到脫褲呢
應該是說會輸到脫褲啦
不會啦 這個
你現在就拿那個存股
存股不是每年會有利息嗎
對啊
拿那個利息來玩就可以了
我有發現有些股票
每年都填息的
對啊
每年5 6%填息一歐一路往上
存股底八個有交
對 像這種股票
拿利息出來玩
就好了 就不會拖褲啦
就不會拖褲了
人家就是想跟小哥拖褲
對
好 第二個
比較保守的話
價內是不是越多越好
對 因為價外比較刺激
不過價內大概超過20%
例如說這個旅約加100塊
股價120
超過20% 券商就不大爆價了
因為那種全正券商就沒什麼好賺
沒什麼好賺
對 他就不爆價
所以價內雖然是越度越好
但是太多券商反覆爆價
不然價內會比較保守
好 會比較保守
好的 這個很長一篇
全正就是賭博
是券商又來
兒詐年輕人的圈套
他寫什麼 他寫詐兒
他寫偶德還是詐兒
兒詐兒詐
兒詐年輕人的圈套
遠離全正遠離賭博
遠離賭博口號 slogan
我是覺得這個寫得太過了啦
因為呢
全正有些特殊的地方
他可以玩
而且他期望值比賭博怎麼樣
高很多
所以全陣不是等於賭博
不一樣不一樣
是不一樣的東西喔
沒錯沒錯
他還說了喔
定期定額買進台灣50
並長期持有
保證穩賺不賠
賺到盆滿撥滿
我知道這誰留的了
誰留
古魚留
這怎麼叫古魚留的嘛
好我們來看一下
來強者呢會去找方法
因為我們也不能
你現在不能說
常常去這個澳門去賭博嗎
現在不能亂出國
中港澳都不行
可是我們在全正市場上
是有很多方法交易
可以幫我們做我們提高很多省率的
所以我們強者會找方法
那洛澤 洛澤找你
這個不好啦
這個券商坑殺人
這風險太高了
那你找一堆理由
那可能你就
你就沒辦法享受全正的美妙了
不過小哥講得很好
你還是可以存股喔
存股會配席
配著席來做權政
那配席來玩
對這樣子你的心理壓力會比較低
沒錯
如果全部完權政那壓力也太大
好
所以權政到底跟賭博有什麼不一樣
好我們來看一下
我特別畫一張圖
因為賭博它是一個長期
有沒有有一句話說
九賭必輸
對
其實你看我們總統大選開盤
其實我們跟小哥也有賭
我有贏
怎麼會這樣
只賭一次
只賭一次會贏
那九賭呢
他就容易輸了
因為例如說你去玩那個骰子
玩骰寶
這個每玩一次
100塊進去玩
大概只剩97塊都出來而已
因為他有一個輸率
看你對賭也頗有興趣
很有研究
輸率最低的叫做Bridge
好Bridge
不過那個是比較長
有要講的比較多一點
那因為有輸率的關係
所以我們的在賭場上面的金額
我畫一下
基德會長得像這樣
他會這樣子
他會波動
可是他這個波動
他長期而言會往下
所以你記得一件事情
就是你要選擇
你賺錢的時候要離場
賺錢快速離場
賺錢的時候
不要練戰對不對
在線的上面
就是你賺錢的時候
你賺錢的時候
你一定要離場
九賭就容易輸錢了
真的 可是賭神
都是最後把梳哈引達
然後用特異功能換牌
那很練 你看太多
賭博最怕什麼
最怕爛屁股
什麼叫爛屁股
就是前面贏後面輸光光
後面輸了就一直做
做到輸光為止
有的時候後面就輸光為止
好
所以呢賭博不要這樣子
好 這樣子就這個
所以賭博是小哥
覺得賺了就要管他離場
權正不一樣嗎
權正不一樣
權正我也賺了就離場啊
對啊 權正我們可以
今天買 明天就離場啊
對 但最重要的是
明天輸錢還是得離場
全正最怕人家輸錢不離場
最怕爛屁股
所以我們這次特別準備一些考題
因為我是老師嘛 要考了
多考幾次
你們對全正就會越有想法
我們上次講太多公式了
就會熟能生巧
對 上次講太多公式
就有人說
公式太多太複雜
沒關係 我們直接考試
考試直接看數字
好
數字最簡單了
來第一題
在其他條件都一樣
你約假到期的隱含波動力槓桿
那你什麼
起來都一樣了
你只要考慮價格就好了
來 1 跟 1.01
還有 0.1 跟 0.1
這兩個比賽 我回想一下上一集
上一集大家也可以回去看一下
上一集在這邊就是所謂的價差比
對 價差比
價差比要越小越好
對 好 趙懷記得這個口訣
所以如果是1.01跟1
或是0.1跟0.1
這個價差比應該比較小
對 沒錯
所以選小的就對了
對 所以答對了
然後照顧管是學霸
難怪你會叫小哥比較大哥
為什麼
因為要選小的
選小的
這個A會比較好
可是我們很多人他都會選B
為什麼呢
你知道為什麼選B嗎
因為選B他打電話給營員
感覺自己就是個大戶
喔 他講得便宜的
寶貝冷霸丟
兩百張大選
兩百張兩萬塊而已
感覺是個大物啦
享受一下這種
對對對
因為這個你可以買很多張
好
不過這種權證比較不好
它其實比一小
導致它的唯買賣價格低
喔
你會很難離場
很難脫手
對 因為你買的時候
就跟買到鑽石一樣
對 買0.1
你還要等到唯買漲10%
你才能脫手
這個就比較難脫手
就比較難出場啦
好 所以我們
所以價差比要小的
大家不要忘記
好 權證的
第一個考試
那第二個還要再考嗎
來 第二個
Gar的
來 想想考
這個群譯99.01是109年9月到期
對
那麼109年10月到期的
怎麼辦
那就 91001
你這樣子你的編碼太長
好 編碼要固定
多一個字而已
不能太長
不能太長 那就那個
九...
為什麼
Arktober
啊...
Arktober不行
十月就Arktober啊
因為很多人英文也沒學好
他不曉得Arktober是十月啊
我跟你講Arktober
搞不好是十二月對不對
他不知道
所以呢
這個我們正確答案
是群譯九A
A
九A-01
A跟這有什麼關係
那10月就A 11月B 12月C
就ABC代表11 12
因為這樣子比較簡單
這個沒有讀過書的人也可以知道
不然那Tobo真的滿懶的
人人都忘記了
好 還要考啦
回顧一下這一檔
因為上次我們在節目上有提
這個節目上這個趙瓦講什麼久久的
愛你久久
對 你是唯一
上次回去跪算盤了
所以我們要把它寫
快炒99
不要寫愛你99
這麼江湖耶
群藝99 夠01
那我們記得我們在這個點
我們有說
講這檔股票
你不要去追 不要去追
為什麼
因為有關鍵分點
各位看一下
關鍵分點在這邊
賣了1萬多張
這1天賣1萬多張
它從高點
這個11塊6的地方就跌到今天
今天我看剩10塊5
我們來回顧第一集小哥提醒的事情
真的驗證了
所以這些其實我們都可以提早預知的
那我們再看
他的權證的買價原本有到2點多的
剛剛我看剩1.46
剩1.46
一下就崩了大概5
所以權證你一定要玩短線
對 你不要抱太久啦
抱太久就比較危險
所以上次小哥也考我
美式歐式要選什麼嗎
對 美式歐式選什麼
管他的 不管他
又沒有長相思熟
沒錯 對
管他美國人 歐洲人
好用就好
對 沒錯
來 接下來問題最難的
全政跟婚姻的共同遺憾是
共同遺憾是什麼
好 我不知道網友怎麼想啦
網友可以猜一下
如果趙華對權正跟婚姻的共同遺憾
就是我太晚遇到小哥了
太晚遇到小哥了
不行 不要聊 不要聊
好 那共同遺憾
早點就是你有權正就賺錢啦
不是 早點就是你
你就還沒結婚啊
不要
好啦 那我來公布答案好了
好 公布答案
權正跟婚姻的共同遺憾是什麼
是什麼 共同遺憾是什麼
是什麼 小哥的遺憾是什麼
可以啊 可以啊
我們這個有分級嗎
我們晚上11點
晚上11點
不 可以
共同一下叫做
不告等
什麼
你知道這個叫不告等
聽不懂
太秀 聽不懂
我們現在講婚姻
聲音什麼叫不告等
沒有 我們有遇過這個問題
所以這個不清楚
對
來
不告等
是這個不告等
沒教堂
你想去哪裡了
沒有
我們是理財節目不是兩性節目
我想說小哥怎麼會有這個困擾
應該沒有 我不是在賣藥的
我們想不夠等
特別給各位看一下
這是我參加一個學員的婚禮
小哥的學員
小學員 那這學員很特別
因為我們那個學員
那個演習是這樣子
那個演習叫做全陣魯蛇影
還有這種影啊
全陣魯蛇影
我們這個廣納各家魯蛇
就會學生上書很大的
書很大的 那我們要過來評比
對
我過來評比之後我們選了幾個
然後他就跟著我
這個人他就跟著我大概半年
我們半年呢
每個禮拜呢就聚會一次這樣子
這是上次是凱基辦的
然後後來呢
賺到怎麼樣
賺到去沖繩教堂辦婚禮
取一個美嬌娘
然後我就順便跟他去沖繩玩
聽說你挑這個學員
他有口條跟顏值都要挑
對對對
口條
這學員口調好 顏值高
但是要賠很大
要賠很大
喔
那我們那
挑那幾個學員
真的後面還不錯
對 要單身未婚
對 他們都未婚
陳俊成 陳俊成
在叫你啦
趕快參加一下
全正魯蛇營
要參加
我們這次有一個學員
他來參加的時候
他只有十萬塊
對
他後來已經到三百多萬了
哇
他是每年玩除權席
對
喔 每年玩除權席
那等一下小哥會教嗎
我們這集沒辦法教
下一集會講
對 之後再講
完到我都會講說那你幫我買好了
因為我台灣都很厲害
對 是這樣
所以今天小哥要從這個
梅教堂高雄
梅教堂 對
操作全正婚禮
婚姻這些都不告等
因為很多人遺憾
我沒有去教堂參加婚禮
不告等
遺憾這個
不要想歪了
那我們在看
全正也有不告等
全正不告等是
因為他有到期日
是
只有半年而已
沒有辦法擺很長
擺很長
沒有辦法放很長
因為他每天都會損失一個值
叫CTA值
CTA值
因為損失一個叫CTA值
就是持有權證
每天的時間成本
那他會在身分證裡面
也有這個值喔
有有有
我們看一下
像這檔他的CTA值
就-0.02
我要怎麼判斷這個值的高低呢
我們大概這樣
大概每天少個1%算正常
1%算正常
不過這個算很多趴
因為這個才0.29
他就少0.02
這大概少了快7%
因為這個已經快到齊了
快到齊的細塔子會減損很快
所以細塔子每天減少1%
小哥覺得還正常
可是像這很快到期的
他就6 7 8%都有可能會去
都有可能有又有10幾%的喔
但他一定是負的嘛對不對
下子一定負的
好 所以每一檔的系塔子
剛開始也都不一樣
都不一樣
好 好
你的時間越長
對
你系塔子會越小
那快到期的系塔子就會變大
喔 所以系塔子會每天這樣變
變動 對
那我要怎麼從系塔子挑選證呢
我們這個
系塔子其實我們不會很介意
對
只會告訴各位說
這個細塔子是全陣很大的一個傷害
所以你買全陣一定不要擺太久
是
你假如沒有擺太久
你很容易就在全陣上面賺到錢
有很多人在全陣賺不到錢
他最大的原因就是他套牢不去賣
全陣好像真的沒辦法拗
他就套牢他就
對啊他就一直撐啊
我要撐到解套為止
那還沒解套就半年就到了
所以全陣是最不適合長香思手
不適合跟他硬拗的
不能跟全政談戀愛
好 所以純股主很痛苦
他領到股息做這個
他思維要完全不一樣
對 要不一樣
對 然後玩這個就接買明天賣
對
那我們都會挑時間來做
挑時間來做呢
就會比較好一點
好 那你沒確認
那個學員不要結婚了
什麼學友
因為他那麼愛短進短出
那他老婆可能不是很開心
好
好 我看他下子
下子就是買進全政
每天減水的時間價值
越小越好
通常其實越小的
他的槓桿會比較低一點
越小代表他的槓桿比較低
因為他就槓桿就放大
所以你可能就要判斷一下
你假如要擺很長的
你就挑小一點
你假如今天買MiniMine
那沒關係 沒差
一天就算了 一天就給他
這就跟我們那時候說
挑價內加外有類似的想法
如果你很保守就挑價內多的
如果你想薄一把的就挑價外的
所以這有他的概念
那細打紙就不用太K了
你才一天而已
好
一天就給他了
就給他了
對
那你要放一段時間的
那下子就要多注意一點
哦
是這樣子
就要注意他減損的狀況對不對
沒錯
好
那像遮擋權政啊
他的下子啊
他是這個蠻大的
可是呢他就怎麼樣
因為下子大所以高風險
拼高獲利
因為下子大
他每天都要減損大概7 8%嘛
對
高風險
白酒的高風險嘛
對
可是高風險代表他有高獲利
可是這個我不敢
我回到那個網友的想法
這不就賭博嗎 他高槓敢
其實我覺得買權證
就像你去開個麵店
去擺個地攤
你總是要有點租金給別人
對不對
那我們這個拚大的人
那些租金可能就貴
你可以這樣想
你要熱門地段就對了
熱門地段租金貴
那我們來看這個高獲利
像這樣權證
例如說在平盤的時候
它的合理價0.29
然後呢 漲停板
0.74
你看這個賺多少
兩三倍的漲幅
對 兩三倍的漲幅
那這漲停板呢
就賺了這個0.45
對 漲停板賺0.45
跌停呢
0.03
跌0.03 幾乎沒有價值
可是你才跌0.26而已
對 你要這樣想
上檔空間是下檔一兩倍
對 上面0.45
底下才0.26
所以全正這個是一個很好的優點
這個怎麼有點像我們剛剛兩體重
這優點為什麼很好
舉例來說
假如你知道這家公司明天
不是漲停就跌停
你知道這種事情發生嗎
除非有啊
例如說要發表重大訊息
你不曉得他什麼時候發表
這就比較麻煩
他都突然發表
對 但是明天要公佈財報
這不錯 要公佈財報
法說會嘛 法說又不錯
或是說就是每個月10號要公佈營收
或者每季要公佈季報
那也可以
那個時候你就可以用全程來撥一把
賭到漲停好了
那你就賺多少 賺0.45以上
對
因為漲停外面上面隨便你掛
所以賺0.45以上
跌停還有0.03
即便沒有人跟你買
你最多也賠0.29而已
哦 好 算好自己能夠賠的範圍
獲利跟虧損不成比例
獲利比較多 虧損比較少
那這個就很適合用權力來參與
你知道有一次啊
樂生他就公布說
明天我們就知道白齒乾頭的錢啊
你知道白齒乾頭在阿利嗎
你知道這名字真的很壞
對 他名字為什麼取這個你知道嗎
為什麼
白痴趕頭
太壞了
幸好已經出事了
再罵人你知道嗎
就趕頭我們是笨蛋才趕頭
你看罵人就真的出事了
真的出事了
那樂生那次說只要白痴趕頭
前進來
對
我就能更進一步
前進來就是收購完成了
128塊件
對
前沒進來呢
就12塊8件
就這樣後面這個錢沒進來
就跌到十二塊
所以小哥當時就去買了一缸子的認購
認售
當時你可以買兩種
認購跟認售都買
反正漲停了 認購賺翻了
跌停的認售也就賺翻了
那另外一邊只會賠一點點而已
那個就很適合玩
那現在熱身這種百年不得了
百年熱身這個太難了
那我們有沒有什麼是可以自己判斷的
自己判斷的 好啦來吧
所以呢我們就要跟各位講一下
熱身那個波動很大
其實就很適合用全證
所以呢我們全證呢反過來
我們就要遠離什麼
遠離不賺錢的全證標的
我們先刪除法
不賺錢的通通先刪掉
這樣就可以省很多標的了
沒錯 全證最愛的就是波動
波動 好
我們要遠離低波動的股票
因為全證跟著股票動嗎
所以股票不動 權正就完了
對 沒錯
低波動股票有多恐怖呢
有多恐怖呢
欸 製作單位
製作單位怎麼自給他弄小的
欸 小哥沒波的他不要
欸 不要這樣
不要挖我肯定
壓力好大喔
小哥沒波不要 我壓力真的很大
欸 製作單位不能這樣
我沒有想到你的口味是這樣
沒波動欸 這洞才會又那麼小
你知道我又要掉粉了
我不是叫小哥 我是滴妹的哥哥
喔 難怪他不叫 他叫阿滴嘛
沒波的小哥不要
沒波動的啊
沒波動的不要
沒波沒動的不要
那你會問台中營
你看這種無聊的鑰匙
這純古喜歡的啦 不是你啊
12塊到12塊5
12塊到12塊5混了半年
那你看一下他的權證
台中營 凱基 9301
就一路下跌
他漲的時候有稍微漲一點
漲的時候稍微漲一點
但是會一路下跌
小哥我覺得你講到一個重點
如果存股的人是拿你的股息來玩
你千萬不要回去買你存股標的權證
千萬不要
兩個完全相反的概念
你要拿股息去買那個
你不敢碰的股票
對 玉金光 鍋具
這種越腰越好
好 腰骨才可以
對 腰骨
好
一個沒波了 小哥提出去
又來一個沒波的啊
沒波動的不要
中鋼
中鋼我還可以挑兩檔給各位看
哇 中鋼就是大牛啊
大牛 你看
我們挑認購
認購呢 他漲的時候都有漲
對 漲的時候有漲
一點了就跌很多
對
漲的時候有漲
一點了又跌很多
對
長期而延呢
都是下跌的
對 他骨架不動
可是全身長期
因為時間價值也流失
先下個流失
所以就越來越低
對 讓你說
那我把一陣瘦好了
這就一樣 越來越低
好
疊的時候呢
它會長一點點
但長期而言還是越來越低
所以這種沒撥的
沒撥動的
沒撥的
對啊 不能講沒撥動
小哥換我考你
到底才已經主持人誰有撥呢
人家問老王
老王比較熟
好
對不對
老王會可能跟你講說
某個主持人
好
沒撥的我們講像人寶
人把你看 他這邊盤
股價很盤的
那這邊還特別跟各位講一下
這個投證心中都有一條線
我們把它畫出來
所以要畫他比較高點
連成這樣
投證這條線
我們叫做心中的解套線
他買在哪個價格
那個價格就是他出廠的根據
對
沒到這個價格之前不出廠
結果他買股票都可以出廠
買股票都解套
買全證怎麼樣
一路鐵 它又不出場
對
全陣騙人 坑人
其實是它個人的問題
時間價值的問題
我不要做久了
像我們純果的話還有配戲
沒錯
等填行就賺到那個戲
可是全陣沒有辦法越等越配戲
沒有這回事
對
所以要快速出場
所以我們全陣就要挑時機
好 因為剛剛小哥有告訴我們
像熱身那樣的案子
就是一把賭輸贏
可是還有什麼時間點
可以一把賭輸贏呢
其實在上一集我們有列出四個
對 好 那我們這個要慢慢講
一次講四個 太滿了
一次講四個消化不了啦
消化不了
還是那也是一個法說會
一個除權席 一個要想反彈
一個是布林通道開了 主力買
今天先講第一個
先講法說會錢就好啦
好 那法說會很特別
我們講一個台股
最會法說的股票
還有這種喔 法說王
這個美麗厲害的
好 成像啟風啦
來 美麗呢
我們張表還去把
我以前的獎益找出來的
因為現在要找出資料還不好找
因為美律各位看一下
在2017年
2.470月
這是特別的月份
都是記報差不多已經知道的時候
沒錯 特別月份就1.470
那1月份有時候要過年
過年就晚一點 就2.470
那2470法說會的隔天
因為法說會都是下午說
對
所以這個下午說完之後
法人就會怎麼樣
給買進 平等
或是賣出 或賣出平等
結果在隔天呢
這個他都漲停板
你說每一次這種重大時間的法說
他都漲停板
1470月隔天都漲停板
這個老闆是喜歡在法說會上
放好消息 沒錯
這老闆很厲害 報喜不報憂
而且很特別的是
他有一個關鍵分點
每次法術會前
我們都會看他有沒有買
有買就跟一下
現在還是他嗎
現在還是他
不過那分點有改名字
不過還是他
我們看這個美麗法術
我們有做統計
他在隔天
他上漲機率有54.2%
54.2%
感覺不會到非常高
感覺沒有很多
因為太多法說了
所以這個小法說
我們有統計進去
所以54.2%不高
可是隔天上漲
只要有上漲
平均漲幅是2.9%
比其他天數來看
都是比較大的
最大的一次
等於說法說隔天
都是他上漲幅度最高的一天
那假如下跌的話
只要一下跌
下跌機率大概只有45%
對 就比較低
下跌呢
平均下跌是2.7%
比上漲幅度還要小一點
對 也是所有天數裡面
算是波動比較大的時候
就比較像小哥講的
這檔如果是全正的話
就上漲很多
可是下跌的話其實有限對不對
對 就是我們大波動
大波動都在法收費的隔天
這太奇妙了
都這樣啊
所以對你來說就太棒了
對啊 我們就專門去玩
那個法收費的啊
因為它不只是一翻兩瞪
它還通常是往漲的方向瞪
你生率50%
你也不用怕啊
你生意50%還賺錢
因為你賺得賺比較多
跌得賠比較少
所以那一年光賺美率
哇 這個美率
小哥就已經
飽了飽了飽了
就賺翻了
好 我們來看一下
美率當天
法說位的當天還黑K
隔天立馬拉漲停
那這個人就是
法說位特別之處
OK 所以這是應該說美率這樣的股票
所以如果多找搞不好還有
只是小哥今天先用美律來舉例
但是有很多公司
其實很喜歡在法說會上放好消息
蠻多的
我記得有一次小哥好好講
像雅光在年底喜歡放好消息
像這樣也是一個例子
那個是他們望年會的時候
望年會喜歡放好消息
所以大家知道了
小哥不停的丟訊息給我們
好 做證明
這個美律在法說會隔天
我的資料留下來
2017年的
我為什麼留下來
我每天都有去存那個
全證達人保點
每天存下來
存了好幾年
終於用到了
以後不會讓你常用到
這都大概說
那天的全證
長得我說
那天全證都到齊了
還是找到了
還找到了
這個美麗的全證
各位看一下
那漲跌我
最高漲到147%
這漲幅都
這個看起來都滿誇張的
對最少又有60%
就隨便找都60%以上很多
那這個就是來玩法說
很有趣啊
對 所以我們自己可以來鎖定
自己喜歡的股票
波動大的
然後開玩法說
通常是漲多跌少的對不對
那你要記得下午法說
今天就要買
然後今天買就可以
然後下午法說
就其他要講好的
對 講好的
所以小哥
你現在還有在這樣做嗎
會啊
那下次偷偷告訴我
你在做哪一檔
好 1 4 70 月
特別注意啊
好 1 4 70
對 好
接下來看台股股王大立光
這就比較近的例子對不對
對 近的例子
大立光很特別喔
他的法說位是在年初的
法說位最刺激
年初的 各位看一下
年初通常會稍微節一下
去年第四季和全年的狀況
沒錯 太刺激了
太刺激了
這2018年法說位隔天掌聽版
9.9% 掌聽
2019年法說位隔天
法售貨格天我們看一下這個地方
8.2%
也大漲
2020年法售貨格天4.1%
也算大漲
所以只要年初的大地方法售位
各位就可以參與一下
你曉得認為好
你就去買認購
認為不好
就去買認售
你以為我也不曉得好還是不好
每認購跟認售都買
因為大立光委員跑過
他們家的特色是
財報很少會在法說會前
被哪一家任何一家券商拿到
所以大家真的就是在猜
他會端出什麼東西
所以這家還蠻刺激的
老闆又很老實
老闆又算蠻殷實的
而且買不起線骨
就去買他的權證啊
對啊 權證很多啊
你看那個權證有得很便宜啊
你看大立光法說會隔天
外資就怎麼樣
外資就維持看好平等
有的還調高目標這樣
6000塊
我們不要賭6000塊
我們就買全正就好
不用啦 隔天
大漲就賣掉了
所以這個法書會就這樣子玩
那大立光漲4%全正漲多少呢
給各位看一下
全正漲幅從4幾%到150%
都有
對 10倍以上
對 我隨便挑都4幾%
對
這個是玩法書會好玩的
可是他年初已經過了
我等明年出了
1470月
所以都還可以
都還可以
4月還會拖
4月份你可以考慮
可能你可以考慮去買個
瘦嗎
對啊 因為最近
疫情那麼大對不對
對啊
我們要往比較壞的
可能財報會比較不理想
可是
不過這個法治也蠻特別的
壞消息可能隔天大漲
法人說原來沒有那麼壞
像我們台股現在
跟國際有一點小脫鉤
又會脫鉤
像今天
每一股昨天跌1000 今天
台股沒所跌 收紅啊
收紅啊 對對對
特別 好
所以小哥有給一個暗示喔
就是如果今年第一季
就4月的那一場 那個法說密集期
好像可能瘦的方向
搞不好比購還要多
對 可以觀察一下
看金下多不多
金下比金洗多
那我們就可以
來往瘦的方向走
對 好 因為我要水糖烤
好 那這些水糖烤呢
這個
我們下一集解答
因為剛才我們那四個買權證的點
有一個就是除權席
對 沒錯
所以這邊的話
各位網友幫我們看一下這個題目
各位網友 我們也來做一下
因為下一集我們就會把這個答案
公布給大家
好 除席後的股價
或因為配股會配席而修正
通常會下跌
沒錯 台股會蒸發嘛
對
所以我就買認受權證啊
這受就完蛋了 好聰明喔
好聰明 我看到網友問這個
那麼簡單 大家都不用工作啊
所以我們下一集我們會解答說
那這一題的答案是什麼
下一集會解答
其實偷偷去看我們第一集的留言
小哥有 全正第一集
小哥偷偷的已經回答了
有謝答好不好
因為這個就蠻重要的
全正可不可以當沖
我不知道
可以當沖
全正做那麼短還當沖
對啊 可不可以當沖
我下次講
有一個很像也蠻厲害的人
有跟小哥有長篇大論的討論
對 陳教亮做不重要
好 送譜重要 有量的文賴啊
對不對 我先猜重要啦
好不好 我先猜 我先猜
猜重要 好 我們下集再好好講一下
好 下集好好講 好
好 這一集好不好 那這集的重點呢
其實 這一集的重點來了
我們就是希望各位全身不要擺太久
對 細塔紙呢
這個會讓你的全身價格流失很多
好 苦口婆心啦 對
我怕一直講呢
各位呢 這個還是忘記
所以我們要 湯姆比說的好聽
只好編一首曲
哇 久違了我們第一集小哥有唱歌
真的要唱嗎 有
我上次唱完之後
我臉粉絲團的讚少了蠻短的
沒有耶 小哥我們目前
歌有時候必不要是第一集的點閱最好
這樣 不是掉粉掉很多嗎
一直呂P聽你唱歌
是這樣嗎 是真的
不是因為第一集聽了唱歌之後
就不想再點第二集了
沒有耶 不是這樣子
對 真的要唱嗎
要唱 這個比體重還刺激 來來
古家難玩回
十足裡的一種不脫鞋
埋的是在後輝
神神刻刻捅著我
心非
可知心痛的感覺
套牢就能體味
為什麼又念
我怕有人在轉來
看價盤疊
前遠走高飛
後面這一段很重要
好 製作人
雨傘來上來快點
百百全真不會太難
該看就要看
若不快看 時間假日滿滿山
一路向下回頭太難
回本更漫長
從此迷亂 注定逃不過萬難
好 我們也聽到一點忘了
好聽好聽好聽
勉勵完成大家都合作對不對
我覺得比第一集啊
第一集好一點
更如火純青了
你說編曲嗎
我覺得這一集的點閱
如果沒有20萬
沒有20萬
就不錄了
就不錄囉
所以大家趕快把這集廣傳出去
因為一哥的部分請反覆聽10次
所以小哥這一集
教了我們全正
快速一夜買到會翻倍的全證
所以我們下一集
剛才有看了 造型有列了
總共有四個嘛 對不對
還有儲權席要怎麼做
還有開布林通道家主力買怎麼做
在之後的課程裡面
小時候都會慢慢地告訴我們這些做法
因為很多人都要來留言說
全證是不會賺錢的
全證只會玩到脫褲子
小哥要來破解你這個迷思
當然你的資金配置也很重要
小哥剛才一直耳提面命
你不要把所有的資金去壓全證
你把你唇骨的配洗拿來
碰一些你平常不敢碰的
高波動骨票
你會得到不一樣的成就感
所以大家如果
對全陣有任何的疑問
都歡迎留言給我們
對全陣還是怕的
你也還是可以留言給我們
因為我們下一集就會
針對你的問題來做解答
那我們今天的
歌有仇必報就到這邊囉
我們下一集再見囉
Bye Bye
字幕製作人Zither Harp